the federal government could join the
investigation into what caused a massive
power outage in New York City 73,000
customers across midtown Manhattan last
power-on lost power rather on Saturday
the outage caused major disruption
trapping people and elevators and subway
trains the ice because it was hot
several concerts and Broadway shows were
canceled Kris Van Cleave is in midtown
Manhattan Kris what do we know about
what caused it well good morning Gail
look we know that everyone in New York
is still talking about what happened we
don't know the cause but the city says
they know it wasn't terrorism and it
wasn't a cyber attack now back here this
is one of the spots where Con Ed crews
have been working almost for the last 36
hours trying to repair damage from this
outage what they do know for sure the
systems that should have prevented this
substation from going offline did not
work
electricity crews are working around the
clock to pinpoint what caused the power
outage that blacked out half of
Manhattan's iconic skyline for about
five hours Saturday the city that never
sleeps lost its night light trapping
people in elevators and leaving subway
riders stuck underground for hours the
outage turned off the lights on tens of
thousands attending Jennifer Lopez his
sold-out show at Madison Square Garden
obviously we're gonna reschedule this
show there's the alarm going off coming
everybody in the announcements to
evacuate even our weekend broadcast was
left in the dark lights but on Broadway
the show went on
outside bright lights or not you have to
be in charge wherever you are it's as
simple as that New York City Mayor Bill
DeBlasio had to play damage control
after the 2020 hopeful was campaigning
in Iowa during the blackout we're gonna
hold con Ed's feet to the fire we're
gonna work very closely with them power
company's president Tim Colley says the
outage was not due to high demand or old
age so there's incredible redundancy in
terms of our capacity you say that
you've got redundancy on redundancy and
yet a huge swath of this city was
plunged into darkness for five hours
yeah that's fair the grid is very
reliable on an overall basis the
incident raises questions about the
country's overstressed power grid in its
most recent infrastructure report card
the American Society of Civil Engineers
scored it a d-plus we are pushing our
grid about as hard as we can push it
right now given what we've got Patrick
Miller is an energy sector expert
there's an expectation by the average
consumer that the power is always going
to stay on in reality we have a grid
that runs from Canada all the way down
into Mexico and the fact that it
operates as reliably as it does right
now is an amazing feat
now this blackout on Saturday came on
the 42nd anniversary of the epic 1977
power outage that plunged New York into
darkness and chaos Saturday there were
no reports of any significant problems
no reports of any injuries
Con Ed says it could be weeks before
they know for sure why the lights went
out and that substation went down yeah
one piece of good news
JLo is going to be back on stage at
Madison Square Garden tonight and she's
hoping the lights stay on this time I
heard I heard and everybody was there
Saturday night we'll go back again on
Monday night including me it was my son
was in the subway and he described the
doors open at the station he said it was
so black he didn't he realized where he
was terrified yeah it was very
frightening and because you don't know
exactly what is happening but people
stayed so calm I did a stupid with two
O's move because I had no money so I
went to the bank to get cash out then
your words don't work either don't
realize how much you count on
electricity you don't have it you lose
it
yep all right thank you NYPD
firefighters in coned good good good job